der erste kontakt mit aliens darauf
bereitet sich die nasa vor in den
nächsten 20 jahren soll es passieren
dafür hat die weltraumagentur ein erstes
arbeitspapier vorgelegt jetzt in
kriegszeiten fix dass wissenschaftler
sich ganz konkret auf den ersten kontakt
mit aliens vorbereiten
das hat selbst mich vom hocker die nasa
geht tatsächlich davon aus dass in den
kommenden 20 jahren zum ersten kontakt
kommt es werden also viele von uns noch
erleben um wahrscheinlich ist es sogar
schon mal passiert und nur in
vergessenheit geraten zumindest in eine
richtung
am 15 august 1977 empfingen forscher
state university die observatorien im
etat ein signal aus dem all das einen
anderen ursprung als die bisherigen
signale hatte denn bisher empfingen die
detektoren in ohio nur ein kosmisches
rauschen am big ihr so wurde das
radioteleskop genannt dass etwa eine
minute lang signal kam aus der richtung
des sternbildes schütze und war lauter
als jedes signal da vor und nach diesem
ereignis als der astronom cherryman die
aufzeichnung des signals in die hände
bekam und klingelte er die zeichenfolge
und schrieb ein
daneben seitdem ist das erste
aufgenommene signal als warnsignal
bekannt und das soll in den nächsten 20
jahren wieder passieren allerdings mit
kommunikation in beide richtungen wie
wahrscheinlich das ist habe ich hier bei
klicks und schon öfter thematisiert
immer mehr exoplaneten werden gefunden
und selbst bei uns im sonnensystem
scheint es auf anderen planeten
lebensbedingungen zu geben bei denen
zumindest mikroorganismen existieren
können der rückschluss an viel mehr
orten als bisher gedacht könnte es leben
und damit auch intelligenz geben
der deutsche astronaut ulrich walter
warnt allerdings vor dem ersten kontakt
wenn die weite reise zu uns unternehmen
sucht wahrscheinlich eine neue heimat
will die menschheit also vernichten oder
zumindest unterwerfen
ungeachtet dessen
hat die nasa ein mehr als 300 seiten
dickes papier veröffentlicht das sie mit
der kontaktaufnahme beschäftigt
allerdings schein eines schon klar es
wird schwierig die wissenschaft ist sich
nämlich nicht sicher ob wir menschen in
der lage wären mit außerirdischen zu
kommunizieren denn obwohl wir dank
modernster technologien künstliche und
natürliche signale aus dem all weitaus
besser trennen können als jemals zuvor
ist es gänzlich unklar wie die
kommunikation der außerirdischen abläuft
alle bisher entzifferten schriftzeichen
und sprachen auf der erde hatten als
grundlage eine übersetzung aus der
vergangenheit es gab also immer bereits
eine dechiffrierung aus der damaligen
zeit bei den hieroglyphen war es zum
beispiel der rosetta stein
der text auf ihm war in drei versionen
gemeißelt den büroberufen in demo tisch
und in altgriechisch damit waren die bis
dahin geheimen hieroglyphen
entschlüsselt meiner extraterrestrische
sprache ist das nicht möglich und diese
sprache könnte je nach lebewesen aus
vollkommen unbekannten signalen bestehen
wir kennen ihre sinne nicht sehen hören
riechen schmecken sie nehmen sie signal
in ganz anderen wellen bereichen war und
senden sie auch dort ultraviolet
infrarot oder tief oder hochfrequenter
schall
was sind es für lebewesen sind es
populationen die sich wie pilze über
quadratkilometer erstrecken
oder sind es am mögen die als
gemeinschaft ständig ihr äußeres
verändern es ist also mehr als
unwahrscheinlich dass aliens wie auch
wir töne von sich geben weil auch die
ausbreitung von klang auf jedem planeten
anders ist
wir können also sehr gespannt sein was
beim ersten kontakt passiert mit dem
projekt etikett oben wird schon seit
jahren auf millionen computer nach
signalen aus dem weltraum gesucht jeder
kann es programm auf seinem computer
installieren und mithelfen die
algorithmen werden immer besser und
damit steigt mit der immer stärker
werdenden rechenpower auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit die signale von
aliens aufzuspüren wir können nur hoffen
dass der erste kontakt friedlich sein
wird wo es
überall aliens geben könnte darüber
berichte ich in diesem video werden
jetzt aliens gefunden rekord 715
exoplaneten aufgespürt
hierfür dieses video klicken täglich
wissenschafts news gibt es in der app
und im block 1 klick hier
und ihr seid da und was meint ihr wie
wird der erste kontakt mit aliens
ablaufen diskutiert es mit mir in den
kommentaren allerdings übrigens auch in
der video beschreibung und bis dann
bleibt dran